It's Cake Week here at the show
and we have someone that we're gonna talk to right now
and I'm very excited.
Michaela is here and she is
a nurse in the public health circuit
of the COVID-19 response team in Seattle
and she uses her love of baking
to raise money for racial justice.
Please welcome Michaela Banks.
(audience cheering)
Hi, Michaela.
Oh, wow.
Hi, Drew Barrymore.
Hi, Ross.
Hi.
So listen, I grew up right up there near Seattle.
So, I'm so inspired by what you're doing.
This is great.
Yeah.
Oh, that's great.
What inspired you?
You auction off your cakes and please explain.
Yeah, so all of this started,
I love that cakes and sweet treats are so disarming.
And so, when we talk about racial justice,
it kind of grounds us to this place of seeking justice
for people, seeking rightness for people is sweet.
It's lovely.
And even holding accountable
the parts of myself that cause harm,
that's hard, but it's beautiful.
And so, there's this sentiment about Toni Morrison,
so Dr. Farah Griffin said in "The Pieces I Am" documentary,
Tony Morrison said, "What can I do where I am?"
And so, as I was reflecting on that, I thought,
one of the things I have to give is a baking habit.
So I started auctioning off my first cake
for Equal Justice Initiative
and the heart behind all of this, the whole time,
has been, how can we dive deeper into learning?
What are the issues?
What's going on?
And then, what are people already doing about it?
The work has been happening.
Let's follow in the lead of the heroes
in the streets and the courtrooms and the classrooms.
And so, enjoy a cake while really giving of ourselves
to support what's important.
I like that.
Oh, Michaela.
We love what you are doing
(clapping)
and what you and your cakes represent is so meaningful.
I'm gonna be thinking about that Toni Morrison quote, too.
Yeah.
"Do what you can
"where you are."
I will carry that with us in honor
of your bringing that into a light for us.
And Ross and I would love to bid $5000
to you and donate it towards the NAACP,
a charity we understand is very close to your heart.
Yes.
(audience clapping)
Are you for real?
Yeah!
Keep up that great work.
(clapping)
We applaud you Michaela.
Thank you for coming on the show and shining a light.
And obviously, if you go to the DrewBarrymoreShow.com,
Michaela's work, her website, her Instagram,
everything will be on there
if you would like to join in this as well.
Thank you, Michaela.
(upbeat music)